Nobody's born smart
We all start at 0
Can't talk, can't walk, certainly can't do
algebra
Adding, reading, writing, riding a bike --
Nobody's good at anything at first
There was a time when Einstein couldn't count
to 10, and
Shakespeare had to learn his ABC's
just like the rest of us
Thankfully, we're born to learn
Slowly, surely, you stumble, slip, crawl,
fall, and fail, and fall
Frustrating, confusing, trying, struggling
Until one day, you walk
One foot in front of the other
One idea on top the next
Each wrong answer making your brain a little
bit stronger
Failing is just another word for growing
And you keep going
This is learning
Knowing that you'll get it even if you haven't
gotten it yet.
Because the most beautiful, complex concepts
in the whole universe are built on basic ideas
that anyone can learn, anywhere can understand.
Whoever you are, whereever you are
You only have to know one thing:
You can learn anything